zum ersten mal ist das beamen die
teleportation von informationen ins
weltall glock noch ist das beamen von
materie ein absoluter menschheitstraum
aber daten sind jetzt tatsächlich zum
ersten mal in den weltraum gebiet worden
so ist in zukunft die abhörsichere
kommunikation über große distanzen
möglich ein großes interesse von staaten
deshalb hat auch china
diese erste teleportation bewerkstelligt
und die asiatische diktatur ist hier
schon längst aus dem
experimentierstadium herauskriegt vom
science fiction herzlich willkommen
2012 ist dem wiener professor anton
zeilinger zum ersten mal das beamen über
eine distanz von 143 kilometern gelungen
er teleportiert den quantenzustand eines
lichtteilchen eines photons zwischen den
kanarischen inseln la palma und
teneriffa schon damals sagt er voraus
damit die möglichkeit der teleportation
zu satelliten bewiesen ist
was hat er gemacht zeilinger macht
nichts anderes als sie von albert
einstein als spukhafte verschränkung von
teilchen zu nutzen es ist nämlich
möglich zwei teilchen zu erzeugen wie
exakt den gleichen quantenzustand haben
die gleiche wellenfunktion diese
teilchen sind verschränkt wenn man
selbst fremd dann bleiben sie aber
verbunden
theoretisch ändern sich ihre zustände
synchron egal wie weit sie voneinander
entfernt sind
feininger hat jetzt ein photon auf eine
insel geschickt und das andere auf der
anderen hin will behalten beide
lichtteilchen warm miteinander
verschränkt jetzt hat er das
verbleibende photon mit einem weiteren
foto mit einer anderen wellenfunktion
verschränkt so dass sich dessen wendung
funktion also von den ersten zehn ändert
wird das passierte auch im selben moment
mit dem lichtteilchen auf der anderen
insel da es ja mit dem anderen
photon verschränkt war allerdings war
bisher das problem dass teilchen bei
großen entfernungen verlorengehen
absorbiert werden bzw
die übertragung ja sonst wie gestört
wird deswegen ist die teleportation dass
bienen hier auf der erde über große
distanzen schwierig luftbewegungen
wasserdampf rauchpartikel und so weiter
und so fort machen sie bei größeren
distanzen unmöglich der transporte
verschenken teilchens an einen anderen
ort ist einfach nicht möglich anders ist
das aber bei satelliten im weltall gibt
es keine luft es herrscht ein vakuum das
haben sich die chinesischen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
jetzt zunutze gemacht im vergangenen
juni schickten sie den satelliten - vom
satelliten stadtzentrum in der wüste
gobi aus mit einer rakete vom typ langer
marsch 2d in eine sonnen synchrone
umlaufbahn der satellit passiert so die
bodenstation in tibet jeden tag zum
dunkelsten zeitpunkt um mitternacht
ideal für die kommunikation mit licht
mit lichtteilchen mit photonen innerhalb
von 30 tagen schickten die forscher und
forscherinnen
nacht 4000 verschränkte photonen pro
sekunde zum satelliten
es waren am ende millionen die kürzeste
strecke zwischen den satelliten und der
bodenstation war dabei 500 kilometer
lang und die längste 1000 vielen
kilometer und sogar bei der längsten
entfernung klappte die teleportation 911
mal gab es positive ergebnisse sieht
teleportation war gelungen stolz heißes
wir melden
die erste quanten teleportation von
unabhängigen einzelne photonen kubitz
von einer bodenstation zu einem
satelliten in einer niedrigen
erdumlaufbahn über einen uplink kanal in
einer entfernung von bis zu 1400
kilometern
der vorteil einer solchen com an der
aktion ist die absolute abhörsicherheit
wird der zustand eines teilchens
gemessen wird es dabei verändert das
heißt das ist unmöglich ist irgendwelche
informationen abzufangen wenn in der
hardware keine fehler vorliegen
aber die chinesen sind schon einen
schritt weiter beim abfinden kongress
der kommunistischen partei chinas ende
2012 haben die geheimdienste nichts
darüber erfahren können was dort
entschieden wurde nichts drang nach
außen
für die spione war das unglaublich die
chinesen hatten ein quanten netzwerk
installiert wir können also gespannt
sein wie und ob die chinesische
regierung hier weitere fortschritte
erzielt hier erfahrt ihr natürlich immer
das neueste zum thema so bei xing xu
wenn er kein video verpassen wollt da
dürfen wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke und
hier geht es weiter mit nsa hat keine
chance quanten netzwerks darüber wie
dumm die geheimdienste bei den
chinesischen quanten netzwerken aus der
wäsche gucken ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran